just a little comedy
[Music]
wayne's world
i grew up
near on or about the rough parts of
scarborough in the uh suburbs of toronto
and uh it's very heavy metal and i was a
heavy metal kid this character was just
basically everybody
i knew who talked that way including
myself okay we're just about out of time
right but before we go we'd like to take
a moment here for a wayne's world salute
to the guest jeans girl claudia schiffer
schwing swings ted paul she's a babe
i had done wayne campbell on canadian tv
i first thought i'd done it on stage in
punk clubs and then i got on second city
main stage in toronto
and did a sketch and then there was a
show called it's only rock and roll on
canadian television and i did wayne's
power minute and then i got hired for
cyrene live he was in my trunk of
characters then lauren said do you want
to make a movie he offered me a
different movie and me
being a dummy and not knowing anything
just went no i want to do wayne as a
movie and it was like okay
we got behind it we went to paramount we
made it and we didn't think it was going
to get made we didn't think it was going
to get released
and we didn't think that anybody would
go see it and uh it was an unbelievable
unbelievable joyous surprise that it
just kept being the number one movie for
weeks after weeks let this player say
she makes me feel kind of funny
like when we used to climb the rope in
gym class
i think one of the
biggest leg ups i had was that i was in
a film with dana carvey
who was one of the greatest
comedians to ever be on saturday live i
just learned so much from him i think
the thing i learned
the most because i'm a writer of the
stuff
is that there's writing and then there's
performing
and to enjoy performing he's the most
joyful performer i've ever worked with
if i hadn't worked with dana and
learned that you have to get the fun
molecules into the funnel that get onto
the film i don't think i could have done
austin powers it was just great to work
with somebody that goes yeah we're
supposed to show off
we're supposed to have fun that's why
they came here
austin powers international man of
mystery
so i grew up in canada but my parents
both of them were english and there's
nobody more english than an englishman
who no longer lives in england and my
dad who was very very funny and my
biggest
champion loved comedy loved comedians he
loved all entertainers it was great that
the one that he loved the most was peter
sellers who was english when the pink
panther was on or
even down amongst the zed men more
obscure or the bobo or i'm all right
jack or the ultimate
masterpiece of peter sellers which is uh
doctor strangelove we all aspire to that
we want to touch the hem of that garment
you know i said to my dad he goes what
do you want to do when you grow up get
from liverpool and i said
i know i think i want to be an architect
because why would you want to do that
for
be a comedian
so i had the opposite of what most
people had okay name
austin
danger powers
sex yes please
so for me austin powers was
that kind of
cheeky chappy
it was everything
that my dad was proud of of being
british
but another key ingredient of that was
bert bachrach and that there was a 60s
that bert bachrach embodied that i
hadn't really kind of seen
put into the movies yet the 60s that
most people had done was woodstock
hippies
but the one that i loved was the monied
60s the international man of mystery 60s
and i think the biggest influence was
the movie casino royale
thank you and welcome to france mr bond
i contacted bert bacharach it was my
first call and he agreed to be part of
it and then he agreed to be in it then
elvis costello agreed to be in it ladies
and gentlemen mr burt bacharach
what the world
needs
is love i was talking to my brothers i
talked to my brothers about seven times
a day and i said i thought that you
would have to have grown up in my house
to like austin powers because it was so
specific but again it was such a lovely
surprise that it meant something to
other people other than just me and my
brothers
shrek
to me it
the euro-centric form that is the fairy
tale
is really about classism
when i was approached to do shrek
originally i did it as a canadian and i
re-recorded it
as scottish because that to me seems the
most working class but also too i have a
love of the scottish people i have
scottish ancestry in mostly english but
liverpool is it's the pool of life
between scotland england and ireland
layers
onions have layers ogres have layers
onions have layers
you get it we both have layers
i love the idea of taking a fairy tale
and turning it on its head and having it
be that all the traditional bad guys are
good guys and all the traditional good
guys are bad guys and i realized it's a
dramatic role i mean halfway through i
went there's an emotional center here
you know the old joke i wouldn't want to
be a member of a club that would have me
as a member
i have always felt that way the concept
of going from a self-loathing ogre to a
self-accepting ogre was meaningful to me
i love you
really
really really
i love you too
[Music]
i i love playing shrek if i had to do it
one shrek a year i'd be thrilled
so i married an axe murderer
every actor who's given a script is
given an opportunity to
to shape it and give feedback it was in
san francisco
i was like if it's san francisco should
be beat poems and and beat poetry i love
jack kerouac and i would in my life
would always be there's no telling
what's on the mind of the man going to
the fire that is not there you know i
dug berlin street once white now steamed
with gum that sort of
fun kerouac
thing so i thought well i'll make him a
beat poet
in san francisco
[Music]
she stole my heart and my cat
i wanted it to be
a genre mix because
you know there's a point in a man's life
when he's decided to get married and
there is a part of them that feels that
that makes them ever more closer to
dying
as much as they're happy to be married
there is a well if i'm married then it's
kids and if it's kids then i'm retired
then i'm dead and so there is a sense of
one's own mortality at that moment so i
wanted to uh
be a comedy thriller wait
why don't you just taste it it's got
strawberries in it you love strawberries
taste and taste i spend 20 minutes
making it just take a sip one i'm just
gonna go i'm just gonna go okay
i am just so incredibly
uh grateful
i i have to this day people
saying to me heed move
hide move
it's been a great
surprising fantastic experience that
it's
stayed around
it's a pentaverit
i've been obsessed with secret societies
and i put into the script of so i
married an axe murderer that the
scottish father is obsessed with
a group of people called the pentavret
who control everything well it's a
well-known fact sunny jim that there's a
secret society of the five wealthiest
people in the world known as the
who run everything in the world
including the newspapers and meet
tri-annually at the secret country
mansion in colorado known as
the meadows i've just seen the culture
since i did that long time ago
get more and more into conspiracy
theories so i thought well
let's bring back the pentavarite you
know y'all just kidnapped a black man
we've been kidnapping white men for
years we want to give you an opportunity
as well forget about him
basically we're the good guys
we want you to trust us why should i
trust you white man
whiter man
older whiter man
i don't know what the hell they make out
of you
i was just sitting around and i thought
i grew up in a country where we like the
government it's just canada and we like
experts you know i mean
and people who are experts are kind of
taking a beating right now but i thought
well what if there was a secret society
of five
people
uh what if they were actually nice and
what if i played all five people and
what have i also played
the guy
who was exposing
the
secret society and what if he was a
local journalist because i think local
journalists are taking a beating as well
but i wanted it to be silly and fun and
i wanted to be cinematic and i wanted to
be a ride a fun ride like what i was
hoping for with austin powers and with
wayne's world i just thought that
everyone's talking about this serious
thing in a very serious way um i would
like to talk about this serious thing in
a silly way
and
do what i'd love to do which is
characters the makeup man louis zakarian
the same guy worked with at saturday
night live as a genius made these
fantastic character
makeups for me and i had a great
brilliant director in tim kirkby who's
english and eccentric and was able to
piece it all together
i just think that water will
find
its right level and i think
that once the people start to trust the
experts again and once the experts start
to serve the people that's also
including everybody where it's all
inclusive i think we're going to be okay
and i i i have to think that way too
because i have three kids under the age
of 10. so i have to
send that into the world that which i
would want it to be